taliban sources have revealed to al
jazeera what a future government in
afghanistan might look like it is going
to be headed by an emerald moment or the
leader of the faithful under him is
going to be a leadership council or a
rahmarishura this is the shooter which
is convened in afghanistan for the first
time in 20 years leaders from all over
the world as well as neighboring
countries have traveled there we know
mullah brother is in kabul mulayakub has
traveled from kandahar and they are
holding their consultative meetings on
the future shape of the government the
key ministries include the ministry of
defense the ministry of interior
security a special ministry for kabul uh
ministry of finance ministry of public
affairs as well as judicial uh system
taliban say that it is going to be
paramount that this system is run under
the sharia law which they aspire to
sources have also told us that an
interim government is also in the offing
and in that ministries are going to be
given to other parties who have been
fighting taliban or at least have been
on the other side with the previous
government now the taliban want a
complete change of faith in these
ministries and they have been in contact
with the united states uh where the
united states government wants mohammed
karzai
abdullah
to be part of this
transitional government or an interim
government taliban sources have not
revealed whether this government which
is going to come into place in a matter
of weeks we've been told is either going
to work under the same constitution that
afghanistan is run under now or it is
going to be reverted to the constitution
that the taliban made in 1996. sources
in doha have told al jazeera the taliban
remain committed to not letting their
soil be used by any other groups such as
al-qaeda these statements have been made
before and they continue to reiterate
these statements but we've heard from
the united states the united nations
nato and other leaders saying that
taliban can make all these statements
but the proof is going to be in the
pudding on what their actions are going
to look like on the ground not in just
in terms of what the formation of the
government is going to look like but
what are going to be the basic
principles and tenets of this government
as taliban have said that they are going
to continue to abide by international
laws as well as rights for minorities
and women and other groups under the
ambit of sharia this is the sharia which
taliban believes in and it is still
ambiguous on what is it going to look
like on the ground when it is
implemented